venu à questions d'info terrorisme
montée des extrêmes crise
face à la montée des périls le temps est
il venu de pratiquer de l'union sacrée
et puis françois hollande peut-il
vraiment être un homme de synthèse
invité de questions d'info aujourd'hui
françois bayrou le président du modem et
le maire de pau est à mes côtés pour
vous interroger monsieur bayrou
françoise fressoz du monde frédéric
dumoulin de la fp et marie-eve malouines
de france info alors si l'emploi
françois hollande dit il n'y aura de
l'emploi que s'il ya de la croissance
il ajoute que l'essentiel c'est la
confiance c'est le moteur est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec ce constat est
ce que vous pensez que la confiance peut
revenir d'ici la fin de ce qu'il sait
c'est l'actualité qui veut ça donc c'est
le genre de déclaration qui enfonce des
portes ouvertes et qu'il y à peu près ce
que tout le monde pense j'ai une vision
un tout petit peu différente
je pense qu'il n'y aura de reprise de
l'emploi réellement est d'ailleurs de
croissance que si le monde des créateurs
d'activités des entrepreneurs de ceux
qui innovent qui ont des idées pour
l'avenir et suffisamment assurée de sa
situation dans la société française pour
y aller de bon coeur c'est ça la
confiance je sais pas si c'est ça la
confiance mais ça signifie par exemple
que il faut retrouver la sécurité
juridique la sécurité fiscale le fait
qu' on sache à un an deux ans trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans huit ans où on va ne
pas changer de loi tous sont à peu près
les deux puisque arrêter de multiplier
par au delà arrêter de multiplier les
lois les textes les règlements les
normes les contrôles de toute nature le
plus souvent infondés qui donne à tous
ceux qui sont créateurs d'emplois klata
d'activité et d'emploi parce que les
deux vont ensemble un sentiment
d'insécurité dans le moyen terme mais au
niveau des indicateurs actuels et scala
qui vous rendre optimiste ou au
contraire vous êtes encore trouvé ça
vous laisse le jeu
je crois avoir dit à ce micro que je
partageais pas l'optimisme général sur
le fait que la baisse de l'euro
conjuguée à la baisse du pétrole
allaient nous rendre l'activité
je ne pense pas ça parce que je pense
qu'il n'ya de 2,2 bon vent de bonne
métérologiques pour les bateaux qui sont
sains et en bonne santé
dans ce que vous dites ou pas non pour
l'instant on n'a rien fait de
fondamental et si vous observez les
chiffres d'une part les déclarations de
tous les deux tout les observateurs par
exemple de l'union européenne sur la
situation de la france ils disent tous
la même chose
la baisse du chômage du mois de janvier
ça va c'est quoi c'est un épiphénomène
vous êtes vous-même désolé il ya
quelques semaines en disant que voilà
sur la loi macron alors qu'était un
petit pas la vie dit fin la droite et la
gauche ont été incapables de s'engager
c'est exactement les français on après
les ratés alors il ya deux raisons
principales la situation que je décris
qui est une situation de perpétuels
insécurité il ya deux raisons
principales premièrement le fait qu' on
ne voit pas clair l'absence de vision le
fait que les dirigeants successifs où
les gouvernants successifs n'arrive pas
à expliquer clairement au pays
peut-être parce qu'il ne le voit pas
dans quelle direction il faut arrêter
tout ça dans même ça que sarkozy ont
loué oui bah ça fait 15 ans disons que
la courbe des 100 perpétuellement c'est
à peu près ça et donc le il n'y a pas de
réel changement de réelle rupture si
vous prenez le déficit la dette la
situation de l'emploi
l'absence de croissance tout ça va à peu
près dans le même sens depuis 15 ans
donc à sens de vision et deuxièmement il
n'ya pas le l'assise politique pour
qu'une politique courageuse puisse être
mise en place
alors vous venez de citer la loire
politique majorité la loi macron wepad
assise politique c'est de la musique où
il faudrait construire ont pour m
jean et on appelait ça autrefois et j'y
suis très attaché les majorités d'idées
on pourrait imaginer que sur trois
quatre cinq grands sujets le monde des
responsables politiques soient capables
de mettre de côté ses querelles et ces
affrontements pour dire on va aller de
l'avant et ça au moins on va le faire et
est ce que ça peut se faire ça c'est une
majorité d'idées ce qu'on peut les
trouver
avant à deux ans deux ans et demi ne
peut pas charlie se trouve même pas on
ne peut pas les trouver avant l'élection
présidentielle parce que françoise
fressoz vous l'avez écrit et je crois
que vous avez raison parce que notre
pratique politique commande et non pas
par nos institutions mais par les règles
électorales l'empêchent on est dans un
système qui est un système complètement
faux complètement artificiel dans lequel
la représentation du pays n'est pas
juste qu'avec toile vous parlez de la
loi électorale au lectorat est donc
proportionnelle en cause et le réseau la
république a visiblement tourné là
dessus si vous oui apparemment après on
va voir ce qui va se passer après le
résultat des élections locales du mois
de mars
vous n'avez pas idée qui pourrait y
avoir une réforme électorale je n'y ai
je ne renoncerai jamais parce que je ne
parle pas de décision d'opportunité le
décision agréable pour les ans aux
agréables pour les autres je parle des
fondamentaux de notre pays
le la situation dans laquelle nous
sommes est une situation malsaine et
dangereuse elle est malsaine
parce que quand vous avez 50 % des
français qui ne sont pas représentés
alors je refais le calcul parce que vos
confrères et consoeurs mans interrogé
sur ce point avec des points
d'interrogation si vous prenez les
derniers sondages d'intentions de vote
présidentielles qui traduisent le mieux
les grands courants du pays intentions
de vote présidentielles avec des
candidatures qu'ils sont absolument pas
d'actualité mais ce qu'on sent au fond
le front national est mesurée à entre 25
et 30% voire
voire 33 dans un sondage récent je suis
moi-même mesurer autour de 11 et
quelquefois plus selon les périodes % et
mais jean-luc mélenchon comme image de
front de gauche on va dire est lui aussi
autour de 19 10 quelque chose comme ça
si vous additionnez 9 et 11 et 30 ça
fait cinquante et vous avez donc 50% des
des français des électeurs français qui
n'ont aucune représentation dont la voix
dont le n'est pas présente dans les
débats l'assemblée nationale sauf
épisodiquement le front national à deux
élus j'ai enfin le modem à deux élus et
le front de gauche je crois le parti de
gauche aucun je crois mais enfin vous
voyez bien que tout ça est en réalité
d'une absolue injustice et c'est malsain
et donc il ya urgence à réformer ça je
veux ajouter un argument peu qui n'est
pas souvent repris avec ce ce cette
règle électorale
la voix d'un électeur de gauche à
neuilly ne sert jamais à rien
la voix d'un électeur de droite à saint
denis ne sert jamais à rien pas la peine
qu'ils aillent voter et le centre et le
centre c'est la même chose dans les deux
mais il ya un argument ce moment qui
d'ailleurs est donc tout ça c'est
malsain permettez-moi deuxième et bien
j'y viens la menace fn est bien géré le
fn hamas considère que c'est non
seulement malsain mais dangereux parce
que la règle du scrutin majoritaire
c'est que à un moment elle en l'eau
passe par dessus la digue et jusqu'à ce
seuil
elle empêche la représentation à partir
de ce seuil la elle multiplie la
présentation l'ampli fait que
l'amplifier
oui vous allez et vous avez vous
retrouvé un jour ou l'autre avec 7,7
cette vague qui va en réalité donné ou
qui risquent donc ce que n'est la
totalité bourse de noël
et elle permet justement donc de
représenter tout le monde et elle
empêche annexe est exactement l vernet
trois choses premièrement elle assure la
justice qui est de représenter tous les
grands courants d'opinion tous ceux qui
sont au-dessus de 5% c'est la règle de
tous les pays européens continentaux
premièrement deuxièmement elle permet d
accord entre formations politiques c'est
à dire dans le schéma que je développe
devant vous qui est celui de 2,2
majorité d'idées sur les grands sujets
elle permet cela comme on le voit en
allemagne et troisièmement elle garantit
que s'il y avait un jour risque de voir
des partis politiques qui sont qui
apparaissent comme dangereux alors les
autres formations politiques doivent
prendre le reste c'est à dire que pour
vous et donc c'est à la fois trois
avantages la justice d'un côté la
possibilité d'agir pour des réformateurs
deuxièmement et troisièmement la
garantie qu'il n'y aura pas de risques
pris et ça veut dire que pour vous un la
proportionnelle ce serait un scrutin
entier fun c'est exactement ça non ça
serait un scrutin juste ou parce que les
électeurs du front national ont le droit
d'être représentés et moi qu'il veut et
c'est moi qu'il dit qu'ils me suis
battue comme vous savez toute ma vie
contre cette thèse est cependant jeudi
ses électeurs qui sont des compatriotes
ont le droit le droit indiscutable
d'être représentés il n'y a aucune
raison que les 40% des voix que
représente l'ump le ps ensemble et toute
la représentation c'est 40 ou 45 vous
avez vous avez rencontré quoi qu'est ce
qui leur donne le droit de quelle est la
légitimité qui fait que ces deux partis
dont on peut dire au minimum qui n'ont
pas réussi dans les vingt dernières
années
qu'est ce qui donne le droit que c'est
de l'art ti la totalité de la russie
depuis 2002 rencontre à plusieurs
reprises françois hollande le président
de république voulait reparler de ça est
ce que vous avez l'impression qui peut
évoluer sur ce sujet parce que en
dernier lieu c'est lui qui décide
après le départemental en dernier lieu
c'est lui qui décide en dernier lieu
c'est les citoyens français qui
décideront des reversements où le
parlement bah les citoyens français
au bout du compte alors vous me demandez
oui j'ai très souvent parler de ce sujet
à françois hollande
j'ai même eu plusieurs fois l'impression
de l'avoir convaincu
excusez moi de vous dire j'avais
tellement l'impression de l'avoir
convaincu sur ce sujet crucial que
c'était son programme le programme qu'il
a présentée devant les français étaient
les engagements qu'il a pris devant les
français allaient dans le sens d'une
introduction à quotité d'accord d'une
introduction de proportionnelle nicolas
sarkozy aussi ils sont tous d'accord
pour parler et ils ne font jamais rien
mais voilà quand on vous en allant des
règles impression pour vous c'est pas
une association du dose de
proportionnelle
c'est éventuellement la proportionnelle
intégrale alors le on pourrait entrer
beaucoup dans les détails de cette
affaire vous avez par exemple un scrutin
en allemagne qui permet d'avoir le choix
par les électeurs dans les
circonscriptions et après un
rééquilibrage qui donne au bout du
compte un résultat qui est un résultat
totalement juste sur sur cette règle de
là mais oui j'ai eu le j'ai eu le
sentiment souvent d'avoir convaincu
france elle c'est faisable
et puis je constate que déclarations
après des déclarations il ya d'abord eu
des moments louvoyant et il ya
maintenant des moments ils parent s
sourd à cet objet de pensée en fait que
le meilleur système ce serait une
proportionnelle intégrale
d'abord je pense pas qu'aujourd'hui on
puisse faire autrement parce que on va
pas se lancer dans un redécoupage des
500 quelques circonscriptions françaises
tout ça est impossible et c'est trop
tard
je dis que pour la justice pour le
besoin de réforme du pays et pour la
sécurité contre des risques si des
risques apparaissait cette loi
électorale est la seule qui répondent
aux exigences du temps alors après il ya
des hommes politiques courageux il ya d
un politique qui renonce au courage ça
c'est une autre chose et pour moi en
tout cas
l'heure est aux hommes politiques
ico femmes politiques courageux et qui
acceptent de deux qui accepte de faire
face à leurs responsabilités et de voir
la gravité des temps françoise
aujourd'hui dans le parisien françois
hollande considère qu'il faut arracher
les électeurs ou fr ou est ce que vous
comprenez cet appel et comment on fait
concrètement je vais vous dire la
manière dont le monde politique français
parlent du front national à perpétuité
matin midi et soir sous forme de leçon
de morale adressé à ses électeurs
potentiels ne me convainc pas du tout
évidemment quand vous faites d'un d'un
d'un courant politique les oubliés du
débat à ce sujet central de la vie
politique est bien à ce moment là vous
lui donnez une capacité de
d'entraînement qui est plus importante
que son poids réel ne l'aurais su poser
et en plus je ne je ne partage pas le le
fait qu'on fasse de ce sujet un sujet de
leçons de morale
si je devais à la place de françois
hollande poser la question qui se pose
aujourd'hui au pays
je dirais que le la question est dans
l'impuissance du monde politique tel
qu'il vit depuis
je sais pas 20 ans l'incapacité à
prendre des décisions allaient maintenir
a expliqué ou à partager avec nos
concitoyens les exigences du moment les
exigences de l'heure le le besoin qu'on
a d'avoir des responsables politiques à
qui on puisse faire confiance sur qui on
puisse s'appuyer dont donner le
sentiment que leur parole est une parole
que on va pouvoir leur faire confiance
qui sont cohérents au travers du temps
c'est cela qui qui qu'il cause le la
poussée extrémiste quand il laisse
entendre
l'ancien président république nicolas
sarkozy lui a soulevé un tollé en
parlant de fn ps comme si donc il y
avait une alliance objective entre le fn
et le ps est ce que cette expression de
fn ps vous a choqué vous aussi aux mains
c'est exactement de l'ordre dé des
slogans publicitaires que le monde
politique utilise pour faire pour mener
le combat
évidemment vous voyez bien que c'est
l'impuissance conjointe l'impuissance
bon choix
mps aussi simple impuissance conjointe
des deux partis de gouvernement au
travers du temps qui explique la montée
du front national monte dangereuse pour
le pays
je veux répéter devant vous que si le
front national l'emportait ses idées et
ses thèses sont mortels pour la france
pas un pays ne pourrait survivre
retrouver arrêta trouvé une force c'est
tout à fait rétabli 2017
je ne sais qu'une chose combattre
défendre des idées et et ne pas servir
l'adversaire j'avais un ami autrefois
pour qui j'ai une pensée affectueuse qui
est mort depuis longtemps et qui me
disait quand tu sais pas quoi faire en
politique pose toi une question demande
toi ce que tu es adversaires voudraient
que tu fasses et fait le contraire
mais alors aujourd'hui et alors demandez
vous ce que marine le pen voudrait qu'on
fasse elle voudrait qu'on parle d'elle
24 heures sur 24 365 jours sur 365 et
qu'on la présente comme l'ennemi public
numéro un si elle est l'ennemi public
numéro un du monde politique
elle recueillera les voix de tous ceux
pour qui le monde politique actuel et la
nuit public numéro mais ceci est donc la
meilleure politique de communication
qu'on puisse faire au service de marine
le pen
moi ce que je propose comme stratégie
vous ce que ump et ps sont les meilleurs
communicants pour marine le pen
oui bien sûr
c'est pour ça qu'elle est c'est pour ça
qu'elles les cultivent de tracts
ambulants concernant la garde des sceaux
christiane taubira saintonge et j'ai
trouvé cette formulation très choquant
parce que c'est une manière de parler
d'une personne humaine comme d'une chose
voyez ce que je veux dire c'est une
manière de c'est une manière de
caricaturés à l'extrême
madame taubira il m'arrive souvent
d'être en désaccord avec elle simplement
le la situation de la politique pénale
en france depuis des décennies et leurs
cours unique à la prison enfin dans
l'imaginaire collectif pas dans la
réalité est évidemment dans la réalité
on en est très loin mais si l'on si l'on
mesuré à quel point la prison est un
pourri soir à quel point tout les
radicalisations dans le banditisme
prennent naissance en prison et tout les
radicalisations dans l'extrémisme
religieux prennent naissance en prison
on envoie en prison des petits voyous on
ressort avec des caïds
on ressort les aidons à vos contraignant
et donc set mais je n'ai pas dit qu'elle
me contredirait je veux simplement dire
que pour ma part je ne veux pas
caricaturer comme on le fait j'essaie
dans le débat politique de m'éloigner
des caricatures parce que les gens n'en
peuvent plus voyez ci avait qu'une seule
chose que je que je ressente comme ceux
qui nous écoutent c'est que ces
perpétuels slogan manière de parler
caricature qui font que quelle que soit
la phrase dite par l'autre temps on est
contre alors on prend et et on explique
que je vais dire des choses par exemple
qui se disent tous les jours dans le
débat on explique que c'est la gauche
qui nous a amenés dans la situation où
nous sommes
dieu sait que je suis en désaccord avec
la
dieu sait que je suis j'ai été souvent
déçu depuis deux ans et demi que
françois hollande est au pouvoir
dieu sait que je suis en désaccord et
même en affrontement avec le choix d'
immobilisme que françois hollande a fait
notamment dans le domaine des
institutions notamment dans le domaine
du droit social notamment dans le
domaine et là ça a été aggravée de la
fiscalité je suis profondément désaccord
mais de là à dire que c'est la gauche
qui nous a amenés où nous sommes c'est
évidemment une contre vérité absolue
suffit de regarder les chiffres du
déficit de la dette et du chômage
prenait ces trois indicateurs entre 2007
et l'élection de nicolas sarkozy et 2015
aujourd'hui et sur ses 8 ans vous allez
voir qu'il s'agit d'une pente qui n'a
jamais arrêté de ceux de s'effondrer
donc il faut une autre venant voir la
douleur on parle d'ailleurs une question
de france aux salariés aussi un contexte
particulier en france qui est la montée
du terrorisme
est ce que vous diriez que l'islamisme
radical et l'extrême droite se
nourrissent l'un l'autre comme le
pensent manuel valls
non non je suis en désaccord avec ça je
pense qu'il y a en france un problème de
terrorisme sur fond de radicalisme
religieux islamistes mais je ne pense
pas qu'il y ait un jeu de vases
communicants qui aille dans le sens du
front national dans cette affaire ça va
dans le sens de caractères insupportable
pour tout citoyen de voir ainsi une
tentative d'instaurer une guerre de
religion avec des violences qui sont
pires que des violences avec des avec
des des gestes et des faits qui sont
d'une barbarie innommable
on peut on peut dire les choses comme ça
et donc j'ai pas envie d'en faire une
lecture politique en disant un haut-fond
ils sont des alliés non je ne je ne
participe pas à cette vision là avec le
débat autour de l'islam
comme nous oui justement manuel valls a
défendu mardi à strasbourg sa vision
d'un islam de france a franchi des
financements étrangers avec des imams
français est-ce que c'est réaliste et
idéaliste enfin comment voyez les choses
comment on peut le dire aujourd'hui ce
qu'on n'a pas réussi de la même vision
que nicolas sarkozy c'est la même vision
que charles pasqua
avant c'est la même vision tellement une
évolution dans cette perspective de de
réunir l'islam de france
oui bon je suis un peu sceptique sur
islam de france l'expression islam de
france
parce que parce que l'islam est une
communauté rue en sens une religion et
une communauté qui ne qui ne s'accommode
guère des frontières je veux dire qu'ils
qui est de la même manière j'ai jamais
pensé qu'il y avait un catholicisme de
france même s'il y a une église en
france ce qui est pas tout à fait la
même chose donc français alors cette
question la mairie oui mais cette
tension heureusement à cette question là
c'est ça ça va un peu dans le sens qui
est donc les musulmans sont musulmans
avant d'être français on n'est pas du
tout pas du tout il faut qu on se mette
en tête que ça n'est pas du même ordre
on est qu'ils ne sont pas musulmans en
france ils sont français sont français à
part entière de la même manière que les
juifs sont français sont français
d'abord et ensuite ils appartiennent à
une communauté reliés par une conviction
religieuse une loi religieuse d
observance de la même manière que les
chrétiens les catholiques les orthodoxes
les protestants sont français avant
d'être catholiques orthodoxes ou
protestant de la même manière que ceux
qui sont athées ou agnostiques ou
bouddhistes ou je ne sais quoi ça n'a
pas à être pris comme première identité
vous comprenez ce que je veux dire la
religion quelle qu'elle soit ne doit pas
être pris comme la première identité
d'une femme d'un homme ou d'une jeune
fille ou d'un garçon
la religion c'est un c'est un croyant
qui vous le dit hein
la religion c'est probablement la chose
la plus personnelle et plus intime la
plus profonde année c'est la ville et
jonah hill et un n'a rien à voir mais
non je me disais quand vous avez le
problème du voile qui est un problème
sur un public j'entends par nicolas
sarkozy d'un tronçon vous savez que
j'avais pris la première circulaire sur
absolu sur le voile communiste de
l'éducation il ya bien donc quand même
d'un terrain interférences à un moment
de l'état écoutez nous avons une loi
alors est ce que c'est une loi de l'état
enfin nous avons une loi
la société française a choisi qu'en
france on ne pouvait pas vivre à visage
couvert que quand vous sortez faut qu'on
puisse regarder votre visage c'est une
loi qui a été votée à l'unanimité je
crois ou en tout cas une très très large
majorité et que j'ai voté moi parce
qu'elle ne dans son texte elle ne
prenait pas en compte une religion des
boucles abstentions elle était je ne
suis pas sûr elle était cette loi elle
touchait toutes les toutes les manières
d'être qui voulaient dissimuler le
visage parce que notre société et celle
du visage découvert comme ça il n'y a
aucune raison d'en changer
je veux dire il faut comprendre que nous
sommes une société avec comme aurait dit
le général de gaulle autrefois son
caractère propre c'est-à-dire cetc c'est
près de deux cultures deux manières
d'être et nous devons y être attachées
et les défendre voilà sur ce point mais
sur la religion je reviens au sujet la
laïcité ça consiste à respecter les
choix profond personnels familiaux de
chacun des français qu'ils soient
croyants ou qu'ils ne le soient pas et à
faire que ce monde là c'est le sens même
de la laïcité forment ensemble un seul
peuple
la hausse
l'origine de laïcs hausse c'est un mot
grec qui veut dire peuple
nous formons un seul peuple bien
qu'ayant des sentiments religieux
différents et il faut que l'état soit là
et la puissance publique pour garantir
le fait que nous allons pouvoir vivre
ensemble et pas nous retrouver dans une
guerre de religion c'est au moins
l'héritage d'un de mes amis qui
s'appelle henri iv est brièvement et
très précisément est ce que ça veut dire
que l'état va prendre en charge la
formation des imams en france 6 cl petit
aider je trouverais ça bien vous savez
le le jas séparation de l'église et de
l'état c'est pas une séparation absolue
c'est un principe de séparation mais
toutes les églises et les cathédrales
elles appartiennent aux collectivités
locales ou à l'état les cathédrales à
l'état les églises aux collectivités
locales
du moins celles qui ont été construites
avant un vingtième 6,5 et donc vous
voyez bien qu'on peut trouver et
personne ne voit ça comme une atteinte à
la laïcité
donc il faut avoir suffisamment de
comment dirais-je de sensibilité de sens
de la nuance et du compromis ce qui est
le cas des pères de la loi de 1905 où il
ya de très grands noms compris laïques
qui ont fait qu'ils ont essayé de
trouver le meilleur équilibre possible
pour qu'on vive ensemble
vous avez parlé tout à l'heure je crois
de caractère de la france va parler du
caractère du centre frédéric dumoulin
win or on a vu que françois hollande
avait fait une apparition surprise hier
à la conférence de presse donnée par
jean louis borloo sur sa fondation pour
l'énergie en afrique
est ce que ça vous a fait sourire je
vous arrivez enfin qu'elle était
maintenant ce si vous me demandez si ça
m'a fait sourire oui franchement oui
donc pourquoi alors je vais je vais
essayer de vous expliquer ça vous y
voyez la récupère ya des gens au nom
comment vous pouvez avoir une idée comme
ça à l'insu du moulin franchement ce jeu
je vous trouve tellement audacieux
insolent vous croyez la moindre trace de
récupération dans ces affaires là veut
très loin de moi cette pensée mais en
fait mais les enfants pour répondre à
vos arrière pensé à vous il ya deux
visions du centre et la première vision
est celle de du parti socialiste de
l'ump est hélas d'un certain nombre ou
d'un nombre certain de ce qui s'intitule
centriste cette vision est que le centre
est une succursale le destin du centre
est d'être une succursale devait à dire
d'être alors on peut employer tous les
mots que vous connaissez la route
secours le strapontin le l'allier
commodes des deux grands partis qui
assurent le monopole du gouvernement
tantôt d'un côté tantôt de l'autre est
d'ailleurs quelques fois les mêmes
qu'ils vont tantôt d'un côté tantôt de
l'autre et moi je défends une autre
vision mais alors radicalement
différentes sur le fond sur le sueur sur
le sur l'esprit des choses sur leur
nature je défends l'autre vision qui est
le centre est un courant politique à
part entière indépendance et la vision
de giscard c'était c'est sur 30 66
ça a été à un moment donné la vision de
giscard et c'était le moment le plus
grand de son histoire ça a été la vision
de dom com robert schuman c'était
lassant traça était la vision de de tous
ceux qui ont créé cette famille
politique dans celle jean louis borloo
et l'enseignement
je ne dirais qu'une question ça je ne
dis rien je répondais aux sourires que
frédéric dumoulin avait avait utilisé et
à celle de jean louis borloo semble
emmerdes de jean louis borloo ne dit je
ne l'aï l'air notamment jean louis
borloo est sorti de la politique et je
veux pas avoir du tout de ce genre de
débats jeudi il est vraiment sorti des
filles jeudi jeudi qu' en tout cas c'est
ce qui dit jeudi que de manière très
très clair pour qui sait lire
il ya ces deux visions le centre qui va
toujours s'instaurer en pseudopode de
d'autres d'autres formations politiques
et vous alors vous voulez le centre qui
que j'ai dont j'ai porté sept dont j'ai
porté l'idée depuis des années et même
le drapeau assez souvent
le centre qui dit nous ne sommes pas
soluble dans une alliance ou dans une
autre nous pouvons être allié à égalité
de droits et de devoirs mais notre
mission est de porter une vision
radicalement différente du débat de
l'organisation politique qui a conduit
la france dans le mur où elle se
trouvera de la majorité des dix ans vous
parliez c'est ça qui peut qui peut doit
être producteur de majorité mais alors
pas soluble un axe un axe central et pas
perpétuellement alignés d'un côté ou de
l'autre et parfois des deux alors vous
n'êtes pas soluble mais on vous entendu
vous êtes a priori derrière alain juppé
oh ben ça c'est très je vais essayer de
le dire de la manière la plus simple à
un aussi bon aujourd'hui il y à un
mouvement de communication qui tend à
faire croire que le destin de la france
va se jouer dans un choix ternaire entre
hollande sarkozy le pen et vous dit si
quelqu'un c'est sale or je vous dis
qu'il y a des millions de français et
j'en suis qui disent franchement va pas
recommencer dans dents dans cette espèce
de fatalité là avec les mêmes caries
nature les mêmes simplisme les mêmes
réflexes de 2 pour moi qui sont pas
profondément civique le la même manière
de raconter des histoires aux gens la
même manière de faire des promesses et
de considérer toujours que ce qui vient
de l'autre camp est horrible vous avez
six minutes même si c'est au mot près ce
que vous venez en 2017
on peut pas voir le même match qu'en
2012 voilà le le sait aujourd'hui la
phobie d'un très grand nombre de
français et une partie du succès de
marine le pen qu'il n'y ait pas d'offres
de renouvellement de la vie politique
française
je suis attaché à cette offre de
renouvellement de la vie politique
française
quand je regarde le paysage politique
comme il est aujourd'hui il ya un
élément qui peut permettre se
renouvellent aurait pu être d'autres
dans d'autres circonstances mais il ya
un élément à une personnalité qui peut
apporter un renouvellement à mes yeux
favorable de la vie politique française
c'est alain juppé voilà pourquoi je dis
en fait je suis alpino valeureusement
madame jeunesse et novations c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose alors on se
demande et d'une certaine manière est
d'une certaine manière simple heureux et
donc je dis arrière et donc et donc je
dis très simplement avec l'idée qui est
la mienne qu' il faut arrêter de poser
les questions uniquement en pensant à
soi même ou à son parc en vous y pensez
comme moi non alors qui parfois sont
partis d'un essai par les politiques eh
bien écoutez peut-être qu'il ya des
moments dans la vie où les choses sont
comme ça alors proposé qu'ils sont
généralement non pendant non laissez moi
philosophes comme je pense que le leur
et est suffisamment préoccupante pour ne
pas dire grave inquiétante peut être
tragique
l'heure est suffisamment grave pour que
on essaie chacun d'entre nous de ne pas
penser à soi même et donc jeudi
puisqu'il y a une possibilité
to7 une possibilité c'est pas c'est pas
une certitude un une possibilité qu'on
renouvelle la proche peu de politique et
que alain juppé paraît pour l'heure en
situation de pouvoir le faire
eh bien je dis je suis avec lui vous
êtes avec les 100 connaissez bien je
suis avec lui sans leur la moindre
comment dirais-je sang le sang le
moindre compromission
je veux dire je suis avec lui sans sans
avoir sans penser à des manoeuvres de
quelque nature qu'elle soit je suis avec
lui parce que il me paraît aujourd'hui
2015 mars 2015 il me paraît aujourd'hui
un élément de renouvellement possible
vous avez vu que c'est très très bien où
est ce que vous pensez qu'il va caler ou
pas non je pense y aller je pense qu'il
est qu'il est déterminé
je pense qu'il est de dire mme inédit
vous avez bien sûr ne vous imaginez pas
que j'aie ses positions mais c'est sans
avoir jamais disais c'est bien celui du
sujet croire qu'ils discutent menthe est
terminée parce que je pense qu'il est
dans un moment heureux de sa vie
politique qu'il a été comme ça arrive à
chacun d'entre nous
très très blessé d'un moment d' injuste
impopularité c'est une injuste et donc
il est heureux comme maire de bordeaux
comme je suis heureux comme maire de pau
c'est une
c'est une fonction que nous remplissons
l'un et l'autre avec bonheur et beaucoup
d'autres mères qui n'ont heureusement en
france cette tentation est donc je pense
qu'il est déterminé après c'est un
combat non pas dur mais éprouvent ils
avaient aussi d'être il avait aussi
d'être heureux quand dans une réunion de
l'ump il est sifflé canton il prononce
le nom de françois bayrou et je pense
qu'il a fait exprès ce jour-là un
lillérois ne serait ce que ça voulait
démontrer
bah je pense que je pense qu'ils étaient
contents de se distinguer de d'autres
intervenants
deux intervenants nicolas sarkozy
qualifie de travelling dans ce sont les
militants au départ qu'il faut
convaincre et pas les français
le jeu c'est que parmi les sympathisants
de l'ump
parmi les adhérents de l'ump
et parmi les militants de l'ump il ya
des gens très bien
il ya des gens qui sont sincèrement
engagés après il ya une frange qui est
une frange keane qui ne rêve que de
stigmatisation et de 2,2 de guerre à
mort contre ceux qui mais je les ai vus
permettez moi de vous dire laissez moi
finir ma course a satisfait les seynois
firme à phrase je les ai vus les mêmes
sensibilités sifflé sur nicolas sarkozy
et même craché sur lui quand il était
avec balladur quand il avait dix mètres
hays jacques chirac pour aller avec et
dope à la dure le les mots les plus les
plus horribles blessant les
condamnations les plus c'était à nicolas
les adresser ses traits c'est très
simple et c'est le ce jour là je crois
qu alain juppé a eu envie de se disent
elles se distinguer on vous connaît
depuis un certain nombre d'années
vous invitez puis enfin candidat
présidentiel et on se dit françois
bayrou quand même qui rêve toujours
d'être présent dans le public
eh bien je regrette si vous croyez que
c'est un rêve
vous ne volonté de servir si vous croyez
que vous ne comprenez pas ce qu'est ce
type de responsables et un rêve dans le
sens à la volonté de servir le pays est
ce que je suis et même à ce que j'ai été
enfin disons je suis dans l'obsession de
l'élection présidentielle écoutez moi
bien non je sais que c'est terriblement
éprouvant c'est le mot que j'indiquais
ya eu une minute c'est terriblement
éprouvant l'élection est terriblement
éprouvante et je crois à l'exercice de
la fonction aussi et il se trouve que je
plaide pour que aujourd'hui nous
regardions la situation en se disant est
ce qu'on peut oublier notre intérêts
personnels ou partisans pour penser à
une démarche plus constructive et
collective
et bien c'est le choix que je fais en
vous disant alain juppé étant cet
élément de renouvellement de suite avec
messi vit pas si les packs web ainsi n'y
est pas on verra
voilà quoi je serai totalement libre
parce que pour être candidat
pourquoi aujourd'hui pour vous alain
juppé incarne le renouvellement mais
parce que seule sa ligne politique
sa manière d'être et sa sensibilité ne
sont pas de celles qui coupe le pays en
désignant les autres comme des ennemis
mais au contraire c'est une ligue de
réformes et de rassemblement il dit faut
faire les choses mais on n'arrivera pas
à les faire les uns contre les autres et
il a dit que la majorité à laquelle il
songé c'était cette majorité d' arc
central que j'ai défini moi-même
majorité souvent la majorité réformiste
qui va de 2 de gens qui se sentent à
gauche et qui sont déçus à des gens qui
sont à droite qui sont réformés ce que
dans votre cas de deux hommes politiques
personnels politiques de premier plan
vous avez vous ai dit à un moment il
faut donner des fessées un certain
qu'ils sont tournés
je ris et je crois même avoir à voir ils
ont vécu cette avoir vécu avec une gifle
il ya longtemps 2002 7
je vais vous dire que les choses aient
qui vous faisait les poches je trouve
consternant que le conseil de leur voilà
que je ne confonds pas avec les
institutions de l'union européenne le
conseil de l'europe ses 47 pays à
l'intérieur desquels excusez du peu il y
à la russie et l'ukraine et
l'azerbaïdjan et quelques autres
démocraties inter sensible que le
conseil de l'europe en soit à ne pas
prendre des positions fortes et
contraignantes sur l'horreur qui se
passe en ukraine sur ce qui s'est passé
il ya quelques mois en crimée laisse se
développer des guerres civiles et en soi
à prendre des décisions pour dire la
france doit prendre une loi
contraignante sur la gifle et la fessée
ça fait déjà ou pas que ses excuses j'y
viens excusez moi je dis ça comme
quelqu'un qui a suffisamment d'enfants
et qui a fait oeuvre d'éducateurs toute
sa vie avec la fessée pour savoir que la
violence n'est pas éducative mais
quelquefois ils arrivent dans la vie que
c'est comme ça si si on veut bon c'est
chacun d'entre nous le sait et a vécu
des donc franchement qu'une institution
comme celle-là en soit arrivé à oublier
l'essentiel pour s'occuper de choses
tellement de bon je trouve que c'est
affligé est ce que c'est de nature à
travers des énoncés de nature un
justement à faire porter le soupçon sur
l'europe qui s'occuperait de choses
secondaires et jamais de l'essentiel je
répète que le conseil de l'europe
ça n'est pas l'union européenne c'est
une institution intergouvernementale et
inter parlementaire qui compte 47 pays
oksana ça n'a rien à voir mais cependant
cette cette espèce de d'égarement dans
dans l'accessoire est affligeant pour
moi derrière question de à chaque fois
qu'on voit un responsable ump il dit il
faut que françois bayrou pour revenir
vers nous s'excuse d'avoir vos théories
sur les langues
voilà voilà
c'est très c'est très très simple quand
je fais des choix je fais des choix
profond j'ai pensé en 2012 que il
fallait une alternance pour la france
pour deux raisons parce que le le chemin
pris l'orientation prise par nicolas
sarkozy me paraissait aller dans un sens
qui ne rendait pas service au pays que
ces résultats me paraissait pour le
moins faible et son action pour le moins
inconsistante jusque là et donc il
fallait une alternance pour que le parti
socialiste soit mise au pied du mur etc
au pied du mur on voit ce que valait son
idéologie qu'il allait abandonner tueuse
et 7 ce choix de l'alternance de 2012
vous vous imaginez pas que que je les ai
jamais l'excusé à bord ni de près ni de
loin je vous dis rully on arrive à la
fin j'étais déçu depuis deux ans et demi
par françois hollande très souvent très
souvent et pour des raisons profondes
j'ai été en désaccord avec lui est
cependant ce choix de l'alternance
il était bon pour le pays étaient
fondées pour le pays
il ya un ami de la sarkozie requis qui
s'appelle à la main que vous voyez que
je vais chercher mes exemples
et qui a dit dans une interview en 2012
si nicolas sarkozy avait été réélu il y
aurait eu des mouvements vives dans le
pays
et bien moi je pense que le ce choix là
était un choix qui a permis au pays de
révéler la vacuité de l'idéologie du ps
et que c'est un pas en avant qui a été
fait c'est la fin de questions d'info
merci françois bayrou